uh good evening i'm matthew spaulding
i'm
a dean of the van anderle graduate
school of government our new graduate
school we've just started here this
semester just launched it
i'm also the vice president of hillsdale
college here in washington dc
welcome to our washington dc campus
um we've got a very good friend of ours
here this evening giving a talk
uh we have uh uh sound
so we're recording and it picks up sound
but the room sound is not being very
friendly to us this evening so you'll
have to bear with us
but uh the videotape will be videotaped
uh and recorded very finely i'm sure um
our co-sponsor this evening i i
would like to to mention is the
claremont institute
uh our speaker is a senior fellow at the
claremont institute
i have uh myself uh went to claremont
been associated with the claremont
institute
uh ryan williams is here somewhere ryan
ryan williams president clinton
institute is here
uh and the institute also puts out the
claremont review of books
if anybody is interested in the best
review of books in the country
it comes from the claremont review so we
thank them for that
and for all the great work and
scholarship that they
encourage and produce um
and as is our custom a student we'll
introduce our speaker this evening
although i would like to say before she
does so that
uh the particular book that our speaker
is talking about this evening on
property the pursuit of happiness i've
i've been working on it is a fine
a very fine piece of scholarship uh in
addition to all of his other great work
as a teacher carmel kukuji is a junior
from franklin
tennessee studying politics and
journalism
she's the culture editor of the
hillsdale collegian and a member of the
dow journalism program
and she's currently earning interning at
the office of representative mark green
here on the washington hills internship
program semester program
carmel
[Applause]
good evening ladies and gentlemen
tonight i have the distinct privilege of
introducing our speaker
dr edward erler mr erler is a professor
emeritus of political science at
california state university
san bernardino he earned his ba from san
jose state university
and his masters and phd in government
from the claremont graduate school
he has published numerous articles on
constitutional topics in journals such
as
interpretation the notre dame journal of
law and the harvard journal of law and
public policy
he was a member of the california
advisory commission on civil rights from
1988 to 2006
and served on the california
constitutional revision commission
in 1996. he is the co-author of the
founders on citizenship
and immigration and author of property
and the pursuit of happiness
lock the declaration of independence
madison and the challenge of the
administrative state
please join me in welcoming dr edward
earlier
[Applause]
well thank you i see a lot of friends in
the audience thank you for
coming tonight and to listen to me
especially on this blustery night
i appreciate the effort you made to
hear my screed
i'd like to say a few things mainly
an outline of sorts of what i have said
in
in the book i hope you all got a copy
when you arrived tonight or at least
some of you did
it contains everything i know
in summary form everything i've learned
over the last
40 or 50 years
it is a defense of the american founding
and the
american regime as you know many
critics insist that the american
founding was radically modern
and as such is something low and
contemptible i don't have to
rehearse the details for you
you are all familiar with them
they are shared by conservatives and
liberals
alike both
reject the principles of the declaration
of independence
those principles which the founders
believe supplied
the authoritative grounds for the
constitution's
authority
now i think most of you know that
john locke had a profound
influence on the american founding
but we must endeavor to understand locke
the way the founders
understood locke
many of you are familiar with the letter
that jefferson wrote to
henry lee when he reflected on the
character of the
declaration of independence he said it
was intended to be an expression of the
american mind
all its authority rests on the
harmonizing sentiments
of the day whether expressed in
conversation
in letters in printed essays or the
elementary books
of public right as aristotle
cicero lock
sydney and somebody named etc
jefferson mentions aristotle together
with locke seemingly unmindful of the
distinction between
ancients and moderns that many
contemporary critics of the founders
find so important
undoubtedly jefferson
read the books of public right with the
eyes of what aristotle
called a frontimos
a practically wise statesman
who understood that prudence practical
wisdom
was the virtue that ruled the sphere of
politics
he certainly understood locke's natural
law
as a reflection or adaptation of
aristotle in other words
jefferson didn't read lock the way
leo strauss redlock
strauss found a radically modern lock
buried deep within his esoteric writings
doing his part to extend the philosophic
project initiated by machiavelli
and continued by hobbes
but strauss's reading of locke was
revolutionary
no one had ever before read locke with
his
skill innovation and penetration
including as far as we know the most
insightful
philosophers it is impossible to believe
that the american founders redlocked the
way strauss
did founders were philosophic statesmen
open to philosophy and guided by the
elementary books of public right
but they were not philosophers
and if we are to understand the founders
the way they
understood themselves we must understand
locked the way
they understood him
as strauss remarked the exoteric lock
the lock the founders read presented an
unbroken line of respectability
that stretches from socrates to lock
it was for this reason that he wielded
an extraordinary great
influence on men of affairs
now locke's influence on the declaration
of
independence is well known now let me
start
there central principle
of the declaration as you all know is
that all
men are created equal
can natural equality ever be a regime
principle
can natural equality
is it really a self-evident truth
and is it a principle that would be
intelligible to classical
political philosophy would it
be a part of aristotelian
natural right
self-evident truth is one that contains
the proof within the terms of the
statement
itself for example
the axiom that things equal to the same
thing
are equal to each other is a
self-evident truth
anyone who understands the term same
and other automatically understands
the term equal
and cannot fail at the same time to
understanding
to understand the meaning
cannot fail at the same time to
understand
the truth of the statement
it is an objective description of the
relation of things
in the world but in what sense
is human quality self evident
we know that there are many natural
inequalities
that exist among human beings not the
least of which are inequalities of
strength
beauty intelligence moral capacity
and social capacity
conclude therefore that it is also a
self-evident truth
that all men are not created equal in
all respects that is also
a self-evident truth they are created
equal in the most
important political respect
in the possession of equal rights
the declaration of course addresses the
question of
political rule who should rule
and who should be ruled
this question is almost always settled
by accident and force
the declaration seeks an answer that
relies
on deliberation and choice
you will all recognize there the
language of the first number of the
federalist
papers whatever inequalities
exist among human beings however
measured
none are great enough to make one human
being or class of human beings naturally
the rulers
of others
as jefferson noted because sir isaac
newton
was superior to others in understanding
he was not therefore lord of the person
or property
of others from a slightly different
point of view
one could say that the inequality
inequality between god and man
is so great that whatever inequalities
exist between
human beings would be insignificant
indeed non-existent
in the eyes of god
thus we might say the doctrine of the
declaration is one of natural
law as well as divine law
clearly indicated not only by its
recognition of a
creator and a created universe
but its invocation of the laws of nature
and nature's god
natural human equality means that no one
can be ruled without his consent
and consent is authorized by the laws of
nature
to establish only the just powers
of government the sovereignty resides
with the people who can withdraw their
consent whenever government
becomes destructive of the ends for
which it was established
the people always reserved the right of
revolution
as the ultimate expression of their
sovereignty government
seeks to substitute elections
for revolution as the constitutional
means for providing
the checks on the power of government
but can equality be a regime principle
that's
the question would aristotle have
approved
of the founders handiwork
many commentators insist that the
declaration limits the purpose of
government
to the security of rights and only the
security
of rights and this is a concept that was
alien to aristotle but the declaration's
final statement about the purpose of
government specifies
the safety and happiness of the people
which the late harry jaffa
accurately pointed out was the alpha and
omega of political life described
in aristotle's politics
if it is true as aristotle remarked
in the politics that man is by nature a
political animal then natural right
or at least at least its potential
is intrinsic to political life
how it manifests itself in any regime
will depend upon political circumstances
in the nicomachean ethics aristotle
argues that natural right is a part of
political right
is a part of political right and while
natural right is
everywhere has the same force or power
it is everywhere changeable it will
exhibit itself differently according to
different political circumstances
even though its validity does not depend
on opinion
or positive law political right is a
combination of conventional
and natural right the exact combination
to be determined by
what the federal is called enlightened
statesmen it is true that natural human
equality
is not classical natural right
classic natural right was inegalitarian
wisdom not consent
was the title to rule the few wise
had by nature the right to rule the many
who are not wise
but in view of the theological political
problem
that confronted political philosophy in
the post-christian
era i say
that equality was the only access to
nature
or natural right available to political
philosophy
this meant that consent would become the
sole
legitimate basis for the just powers of
government
but on the basis of aristotee and
natural right
this did not necessarily mean
or entail a dilution of natural right
nor did it
shrine a right of un wisdom
over wisdom
here's how leo strauss explained it
according to the classics the best way
of meeting
these into these two entirely different
requirements
that for wisdom and that for consent or
freedom
would be that a wise legislator
frame a code that the citizen body
dually persuaded freely adopts
that code straus says
which is as it were the embodiment of
wisdom
must be as little subject to alteration
as possible the rule of law is to take
the place
of the rule of men however wise
now strauss was certainly aware that
this description of the classical
solution
is almost his description of the
manner in which the american
constitution
was framed and adopted with one
important difference
in the place of an individual citizen of
preeminent wisdom
and approved integrity americans
entrusted the framing of the
organic law to a deliberative body
described in the federalists as a select
body of citizens
from whose common deliberation more
wisdom
as well as more safety might be
expected this body produced the
constitution ratified by the consent of
the people
embodied the rule of law
and i think we have right here behind us
that body who embodied the wisdom of the
nation
and produced that document that
reconciled
wisdom and consent which was ratified by
the people
a wise document embodying the rule of
law
and sent it to by the people that was
the reconcili
the reconciliation
that reconciled the need for wisdom
and the need for consent which is the
perfect ground
specified by aristotle as the
requirements of natural right
there they are philadelphia
at the same time the framers were
confident that the constitution's design
would ensure the selection into
constitutional offices
of only those whose patriotism and love
of justice
will be least likely to sacrifice it to
temporary
or partial considerations another quote
from the federalist
thus from the point of view of classical
natural right the american founding
reconciled will
wisdom and consent natural right
and political right and probably the
only way
that it can ever be reconciled
consent more or less sends the
boundaries
to every regime
but it is the real sovereign in every
regime in every free regime
it is the job of philosophical statesmen
in an age of equality
to reconcile the requirements of wisdom
and consent
through politics of public opinion
now there is another way the american
founders
introduced aristotelian natural right
into the regime
they were founding and this was done
on the basis of something that was
either
unknown to aristotle
or entirely rejected by him
the right to private property
can this seeming paradox be explained
well i think so
there can be little doubt that the right
to property was central
or a central principle of the american
founding
the founders understood property in a
comprehensive
sense in a 1792 article
madison wrote the right to property
includes in addition to life and liberty
the right to freedom of speech and the
free exercise of religion
as well as what madison called the
sacred rites
of conscience and madison added
for good measure the freedom to choose
an occupation
the right to be free from government
monopolies
and unequal taxes
the right to property thus protected the
goods of the soul
as well as the goods of the body
founders understanding of property was
derived from lock but i believe
the american founders understood
property to be more extensive and more
dynamic than lock they improved
on lock now the natural right to
property was central to locked second
treatise
a book that was widely read and widely
cited during the founding period
now once a private right to private
property was argued and accepted as
grounded in nature
monarchy and its attendant theological
doctrine of passive
obedience to government was headed for
extinction the rule of property under
the english monarchy
which was subsequently embodied in the
common law
was that the king owned all property in
the realm
and all use of the king's property was
conditioned
on the payment of taxes or service
once however locke articulated the labor
theory of value as the foundation for
the natural right
to property meaning that property
belonged
by right to those who created property
by individual labor
the foundations of monarchy began to
dissolve in 1774
jefferson in a summary view of the
rights of
british america wrote
citing blackstone
our ancestors who migrated hither
were laborers not lawyers
in other words our ancestors were
adherents
of lock not blackstone and the common
law
or to say the same thing our ancestors
were adherents
of natural right labor was the title to
property
not grants or titles advanced by kings
the point of departure for locke was
natural equality
which inevitably results in equality of
rights
life liberty and property
being the sole proprietor of one's life
means self-ownership
property is created by labor the
extension of the exclusive possessions
of oneself
are one's body to the external world
to transform the external world into
something useful
for life labor produces what lot calls
or says is 99.9 of what is valuable
in the world nature and the spontaneous
productions of the earth
are virtually worthless no one had a
right to expropriate property created by
labor without violating the right of
nature
or natural law and there were no lateral
there there were natural law limits on
how much could be accumulated no one had
a right to accumulate
more than he could use or exchange for
other useful items
any accumulation over the use limit
would be subject to spoilage
and would deprive others of the use of
what was given by god
in common to all men once money was
invented however the use limitations
were no longer
enforceable money is not natural
it exists by convention or agreement
gold silver diamonds
have little intrinsic value they are
useless things that never spoil
and the accumulation of these items have
only
what lot calls a fantastical value
and does not deprive anyone of anything
useful for life but the accumulation of
money
does spur production
of useful things
after the invention of money the desire
for acquisition
was emancipated
no limit to accumulation after the
invention of money
thus the age of limits gave way to an
age that recognized no limits on
acquisition
now capital accumulation is the engine
of wealth production for individuals and
for nations
every act of private accumulation acre
increases the stock of goods available
for
consumption most of the world's history
poverty
has been endemic and the greatest
tyranny has been the grinding heel
of poverty capitalism
has been successful in liberating much
of the world from poverty
locke says that god gave the world in
common to men
for their benefit and the greatest
conveniences of life they were capable
to draw
from it god did not lock explains
expect it to remain common and
uncultivated rather
he gave it to the use of the industrious
and
rational the capital system of
accumulation has this advantage
unknown to any other age before private
property
every act of private appropriation is
simultaneously
a contribution to the common good
because it increases the goods and
resources
available for consumption
protection for the natural right to
property provided a common good
for rich and poor that was not available
in the classical world think of that
the idea of rights understood as
claims or reservations against
government was unknown to classical
political philosophy
aristotle's mixed regime which he called
the polity
a combination of oligarchy and democracy
was a re regime in which the interests
of the rich
and the poor serve to check one another
aristotle gave no indication however
that rich and poor
would ever share a common interest
but the right to property supplied such
a common interest that could be
supported equally by rich and poor
both have an interest in the protections
afforded by the right to property the
rich in maintaining their property
and the poor in the prospect of securing
the fruits of their labor
and acquiring property in the future
thus the foundation for republican
government
anchored in the right of property might
hold the prospect
of avoiding the kinds of class
antagonisms
that plagued ancient regimes
aristotle had argued that a mixed regime
with a
large middle class would be the most
stable because the middle class would be
neither rich nor poor
and would serve as a kind of buffer
between the two
antagonistic classes a large middle
class of course
would have been a rarity in the ancient
world
simply because of widespread scarcity
the way of the world was a few wealthy
and many poor
with a still system of private property
and the emancipation of
acquisition wealth could be
produced at a rate hitherto unknown
this increase in abundance makes it
possible to have
large middle class democracies
in which the protection of the right to
property
considered as the most comprehensive
right
will be the first object of government
and that is a quote from federalist
paper number 10.
what is more in constitutional
government of the kind inspired
by lock and fully endorsed by the
founders
justice would be more securely
grounded in nature
on the grounds of aristite and natural
right
there must be what leo strauss called a
reasonable correspondence between the
social hierarchy
and the natural hierarchy
in other words justice must be grounded
in nature
or natural right this was rendered
impossible in the classical world
because of scarcity
what were called aristocracies aristotle
said were most
always almost always thinly disguised
oligarchies the rule of the rich
being rich of course has little to do
with natural inequality
or the possession of the virtues or
talents required
for rule once oligarchy was exposed
it became increasingly easy straus
says to argue from the premise that
natural
inequality has very little to do with
social inequality
that practically or politically speaking
one may safely assume that all men are
by nature
equal that all men have the same
natural rights provided one uses
this rule of thumb as the major premise
for reaching the conclusion
that everyone should be given the same
opportunity as
everyone else thus
the lockheed system adopted and adapted
by the framers
made it possible to improve on the
ancient models from the point of view of
distributive justice
or natural right
pseudo-aristocracy could now be replaced
by genuine aristocracy because
the increase in abundance that resulted
from the emancipation of acquisition
made possible a system of distributive
justice
based upon equal opportunity
where natural talents rather than cat
class
or caste would be the basis for
advancement
strauss quoted jefferson's 1813 letter
to john adams with evident approval
listen to this that form
of government is best jefferson wrote
which provides for the most effectually
for a pure selection of the natural
aristoi
the naturally best into offices of
government
strauss comments that jefferson's
statement reflected
classical political philosophy's answer
to the best
political regime the claim to rule which
is based on merit
on human excellence on virtue
the sentence preceding the one quartered
by strauss is no less remarkable
the natural aristocracy jefferson wrote
i considered as the most precious gift
of nature
for the instruction the trusts and
government of society
and indeed it would have been
inconsistent in creation
to have formed man for the social state
and not to have provided virtue and
wisdom enough to
man it to manage the concerns of society
the existence of the natural error story
is thus proof for jefferson
that creation has designed man for the
social or political state
jefferson thus agrees with aristotle but
man is by nature
a political animal
and the best regime by nature is
aristocracy
pure aristotle
and since it is evident that virtue and
talents have been by nature
scattered with equal hand through all
its conditions
meaning in every class of society
a system of equal opportunity allowing
virtue and talent to rise from all
classes
is a demand of natural right
thus the best regime of classical
political philosophy
could not be realized in the classical
world because of scarcity
because of the prevalence of poverty
it became realizable only after locke
had articulated the natural right to
property
and the american founders had
established a scheme of constitutional
government
designed to protect the right to
property
even though the right to private
property may have been
unknown to aristotle and the
emancipation of
acquisitiveness was wholly
alien to classical political philosophy
it is impossible
not to see the influence of aristotelian
natural right at work
in the creation of the american regime
which for the first time held out the
prospect that genuine aristocracy based
upon natural talents and abilities
could replace the pseudo-aristocracy of
birth and class
that had dominated the past
america is not a radically modern
founding emphatically not so
those critics that we started out with
are wrong
they are absolutely wrong
equality of opportunity not the accident
of birth
was to be the principle of distributive
justice that would animate the american
regime
and this was an expression of genuine
aristotelian natural right
well you might be wondering
the declaration says life liberty and
pursuit of happiness not
property how do you account for that
thanks for asking
the short answer is this
property is a necessary but not
sufficient
condition of human happiness
for aristotle happiness is a life lived
according to the virtues property
and wealth are necessary but acquiring
wealth
in the proper measure is one
virtue it is necessary for happiness
but not sufficient
aristotle one prime example of
locke's influence in america can be seen
in this
familiar passage from george
washington's
first inaugural here's washington
there is no truth more thoroughly
established
than that there exists in the economy
and course of nature
an indissoluble union between virtue and
happiness
between duty and advantage between the
genuine maxims
of an honest and magnanimous policy and
the solid rewards of public prosperity
and felicity since we ought to be no
less persuaded that the propitious
smiles of heaven
can never be expected on a nation that
disregards the eternal rules of order
and right which heaven itself has
ordained
now this statement delineating the
natural
natural connection between virtue and
happiness is
of course perfectly aristotelian
could have been copied right out of
aristotle's
nicomachean ethics thus washington
and madison who wrote this speech
understood the pursuit of happiness to
mean the pursuit
of virtue now
it may surprise you to learn that this
notable sentiment of washington's
was a close paraphrase of a passage from
book one of lox
and essay concerning human understanding
madison if not washington was well
acquainted with locke's essay
and it is easy to see how these two
enlightened statesmen
were led to an understanding of
aristotelian natural right
through a reading of locke
in their reading of the essay the
founders must have been
exceedingly curious to discover that
locke never described
happiness or the pursuit of happiness as
a right
preferring to consider it as a moral
obligation
at one point even averying that it is
a perfection of our nature
that doesn't sound radically modern it
sounds just like aristotle does it not
loc does not as modern critics are want
to do present the
pursuit of happiness as something
idiosyncratic
or subjective rather according to locke
it rests
on a reasoned view of what constitutes
good and evil
happiness is an inclination and tendency
of human nature locke argues
and it is when desires are put to the
service of the ends or
or purposes discerned by reason that the
pursuit of happiness becomes in locke's
terms
our greatest good our greatest good
human happiness depends locke says upon
the distinction between
liberty and license license destroys
genuine liberty because the one who
indiscriminately indulges his passions
is eventually ruled by his passions and
becomes enslaved by them
whereas the one who rules his passions
through reason enjoys the freedom
that accompanies rule locke's reasoning
here stands in stark
contrast to hobbes who
famously insisted that reason was always
subordinate to passion
for lock in contrast reason properly
disciplined
and directed controls passion and desire
and directs the will to what he calls
true
felicity meaning true happiness
it is active reason that forms the
choral core of moral virtue
for luck
this is how pursuit of happiness
became in the declaration of
independence
a both a right and a moral obligation
for the framers understanding the moral
obligation
was political lock in his essay on human
understanding
understands the pursuit of happiness
apart from many regime questions any
regime
understanding there's no talk of
politics in that essay
the framers understood all of our rights
in a political context and they
transformed the pursuit of happiness
into a right as well as a moral
obligation
yeah well you may be wondering where
does that leave us today
and i'll just say all to uh
in a very short statement
i know you're all aware that the supreme
court's ledger domain
has transformed the fifth amendment's
public use requirement into a public
purpose one
public purpose of course is more is a
more expansive concept
which allows the government greater
latitude in
exercising eminent domain
we've already heard blackstone describe
how the common law viewed the king
as the universal landlord
who parcels out property in return for
feudal duties
in the most far-reaching iteration of
the public purpose doctrine
in the case of kilo versus city of new
london and that was in 2005
the court in effect decided that
government holds all property and public
trust
to be distributed based upon its
evaluation of public purpose
and under the kilo rationale the
government has indeed become
the universal landlord
but now the king has been replaced by
the administrative state
it is not entirely an exaggeration to
say that the right to private property
has effectively been
abolished all property is
now hold held in public in trust by
government
and i would say that it's not entirely
an exaggeration to say
that the regime of the founders no
longer exists
and i thank you for listening
[Applause]
we have time for some questions and we
do have some microphones so that the
camera can pick up for a recording if
you would wait for
one of those let's see here please
questions but more importantly
objections
he's a professor so he'll call on you if
you don't have fun okay go ahead
thank you professor uh christopher
harris with unhyphenated america and
the question i have i appreciate
everything you said it's a great talk
the question i have what would be the
mechanism to
undo uh basically turning private
property or
turning all the property over to the
government what mechanisms what steps
should we take or could we take well
the framers had this idea
property was kind of an early warning
system
that we could we can lose our property
and regain our property but
assaults on liberty would always show up
first as assaults upon the right to
property and you could be certain that
assaults on the right to property
would mean that assaults on liberty
would
show up shortly thereafter so that we
should take alarm
immediately when assaults on the right
to property
began it was like an early warning
system
as soon as the right to property in and
they took that to mean
taxation without representation was one
assault on the right to property
but any assault on the right to property
should be taken very very seriously
because
uh the right to liberty would be next
we should have taken alarm many many
years ago
when the supreme court began its
subrosa reinterpretation or amendment of
the constitution
to take public use
out of the constitution to substitute
public purpose and we should have
really demanded that that not be done
but instead no one really made a peep
no one really was too concerned about it
there was
no public outcry as there was after the
the kilo decision you know there was
quite a bit of public outcry
and states were passing laws complaining
about
the kilo decision and so on and so forth
but
uh in the early years more than 50 years
ago
50 you know early 1900s when the supreme
court
began to make its strike
transmogrification of the
fifth amendment and it went relatively
unnoticed that's when we should have
taken alarm
what can be done today well it's going
to be very difficult to roll back
and to regain the right to property but
the main thing is this
what the the the founders saw
the right to property as a bundle of
rights those things that i mentioned to
you freedom of speech
is one of your your right to property uh
the free exercises
you notice today that freedom of speech
is under attack
free exercise of religion is under
attack the rights of conscience are
under attack and that's because it is
part of the right to property
and madison was very extensive expansive
there when he talked about
the the right to property those were all
of the things that were in the right to
property
and an attack on any one of those rights
is an attack on
all of the rights all of those rights
put together those bundle of rights
that madison talked about being the
right to property
that taken together is justice and i
must tell you this that aristotle says
that the thing that preserves regimes
this is in the politics the thing that
preserves
regimes above all is justice
so we can say today that any attack upon
the right to property
is an attack upon justice and the regime
is not going to
survive any outrageous attacks upon
justice and that's what the attack upon
private property
is and what can be done i don't know we
have to roll back that kilo decision
what are the chances of that
you know if the president gets more
appointments to the supreme court
and you know how worried the democrats
are about that
i don't know if that's a solution that
would only be a partial solution at best
but i must say we have to be more
attentive
to that early warning system
which is the gateway to the idea of
justice itself
i think we're in desperate uh straights
uh city of new london
there was an interesting colloquy
between justices scalia
and o'connor and the attorney for the
city of new london they asked him
would it be okay for the the city to
take a motel six by eminent domain and
replace it with a
more luxurious hotel say hilton hotel
if it produced more revenue and this and
the the attorney for
the city uh said yes if it produced more
revenue
which which is a surprising answer
absolutely surprising answer you could
take
private property give it to another
person
if it produced more revenue to the state
or to the city
and later on this the attorney for the
city said
at that point i knew i had won and there
is no
argument none whatsoever that is more
foreign
to what the framers uh of the
constitution had in mind and the framers
of the fifth amendment
uh who was by the way james madison as
well
uh no argument more uh alien to
the founders of the constitution than
what the
attorney for the city of new london
claims
uh won the argument for him before the
supreme court and it probably did
that's astounding anyway
anybody else yes sir oh
professor masooki
well quite often uh property rights or
today are uh distinguished from human
rights
which is the rights all right thinking
people should
embrace right and so
when did madison's expansive notion of
property
which corresponds with ancient natural
right
uh really when was that
um uh questioned and
uh
fall into well
yeah yeah what you say is correct i mean
what we hear
all of the time today is that
the framers put so much emphasis on the
right to property that they forgot about
human rights
they put so much emphasis on the right
to property
and they did so at the expense of human
rights well
they viewed the right to property as a
comprehensive right
it was the comprehensive human right and
they didn't see any distinction or any
separation between human rights and
property rights
property right was the comprehensive
human right madison said
as you have a right to property so you
have a property in your rights
that was his famous statement in the
essay that i
quoted from earlier now
that idea that there was a separation
between human rights and property rights
began with progressivism that is to say
the
the attempt to debunk the american
founding but
in the supreme court it began in the
early 1900s
with this idea that we can
expand government's
role in the economy and government's
role in
managing property and and economic
rights
and that's when they said we've got to
have a more extent
expansive uh notion of when government
can intrude on
on privacy or private rights in order to
help economic rights and so on so that's
that's when that happened
but you're right it's a false dichotomy
to say
property rights and human rights are
opposed to one another that's simply
false
the framers didn't believe that at all
mr teddy
yeah thanks i wanted to go back to the
uh your beginning remarks your opening
remarks
um you know that there's um strong
criticism especially on the right
um like the patentine book right
why liberalism failed yeah
so there are critics he says it's failed
because it was too successful
yeah and that you might put it that way
uh so i would express it this way and
then
ask you to to sort of respond to it
whatever else you can say about
similarities between
aristotle and locke the fact is that
in the moral and philosophic
tradition of the classics
through through through uh the middle
ages
it was always understood that um
acquisitiveness or greed to put the word
on it
uh was considered a vice and something
that ought to be
suppressed or at least greatly
controlled
but you talked a great deal about
emancipation of acquisition for the for
the founders so
those people would say i think that it's
true we've become
fabulously wealthy by this emancipation
but isn't there in fact a connection
between the release of that vice
on the one hand and many many of the
social problems the declining culture
that we have and so on
and even our some declines in our
politics as well
yeah and i understand that i mean uh
capitalism
you know you know increasing wealth uh
emancipation of inquisitiveness
uh is somehow low and loathsome
it's corrupted morality and so on and so
forth but i say that poverty is
poverty corrupted morality as well it
it it it maintained tyranny
of all kinds of sort it it made
oligarchy inevitable it made injustice
inevitable sure the relief of poverty
may seem low in a certain kind of way
but it's a generous in another kind of
way it's humanitarian in another kind of
way yes
it made people perhaps greedy but it
lifted a lot of people
from poverty into maybe
not comfort comfortable existence or not
it made some people rich it made some
people fabulously wealthy but
the argument that goes today from the
people who uh
forget what they're called the the wall
st the never wall street or
what are they called the occupy wall
street people their ideas that
uh is that we we should never
um
because capitalism didn't
elevate everyone equally it should never
have elevated
anyone i mean the the relief of poverty
i think has been a good thing now you
can look back and say well
capitalism is really a rough system
and it's corrupted morality but i don't
think
the the way a sophisticated reading of
lock
yes maybe i i thought somebody was going
to say well wait a minute one of the
severest critics of of lock was leo
strauss
i mean he dug deep into lock and said
you know that guy
read the essay on human stan
understanding and some passages
from the same chapter that you quoted
from
he read the pursuit of happiness as if
it were idiosyncratic
and do your own kind of thing stuff and
you know
pursuit of happiness is whatever you
want it to be well
but the framers didn't read that chapter
the way leo strauss did
they read him uh in an ordinary sense
in the sense in which i read him and
locke talks about
human happiness as being the the
greatest
good uh for human beings and
uh in their greatest end and the
perfection of human nature that's the
way they read him
and they read him in a common sense way
and that was very
morally salutary for the country
and i think it was salutary and you say
well okay we have
capitalism we we raise people out of
property uh poverty some people got
wealthy well you know in the capitalist
system you can't help that right
so should we not raise people out of
poverty
should we not have a middle-class
democracy in which we could have a
system of
equal opportunity in which we could have
a government
a middle-class democracy in which people
who are born
into poverty can by the way
you know what was carter he was a peanut
farmer
he becomes president of the united
states a peanut farmer
born into poverty and other people you
know rich
nixon born into lower
circumstances he could go to college he
goes to law school becomes
president some of you here today i was
born in poverty
i went to college i became a college
professor crying out loud
i mean that's improbable right if i was
born
before the american founding i would
have been
born into the lowest class and i would
have died in the lowest class right
and so you know okay fine that's fine
but because some people got wealthy and
and they became
uh you know corrupt
and they act like rich people and
they're corrupt
and they want to corrupt other people so
we ought not to have
some people elevated out of property uh
poverty because
it's corrupting to other people well i
don't know those are their trade-offs
you know the statesmen in the world look
i'll tell you this
no one everyone is born into a world
that they did not
create am i right about that we're all
born into a world that we didn't create
but we have an obligation to change the
world for the better
we all have that obligation and i always
tell
well i don't see an abundance of young
people here but there are some young
people
my generation has failed the next
the next generation to mine i don't know
how many generations are
behind me now but
being an old guy that i am but i failed
the next generation because i didn't
leave the next generation better off
but the framers of our country were born
into
a world that they did not create but
they move
further and faster than any other
generation
in history
but they couldn't change everything
there were some
intractable problems that they could not
change
but they went further and faster look
the principle of statesmanship
is this
cure as many evils as you can while you
can
without destroying the basis for curing
further evils
you can't do everything if it means that
you
have to bring in locked knew this
locke was well aware of this he wrote a
book called the reasonableness of
christianity
and i can tell you one thing i can tell
you two things are three things but i'll
tell you this one thing
if locke hadn't written uh uh written
that book
and another little book that he wrote
called
what is it called the book on religious
freedom i forget
you know letter on tolerate letter on
toleration
if he hadn't written reasonableness of
christianity and letter on toleration
what made the american founding possible
and i do not exaggerate
is that at the american founding
there was no quarrel between religion
and politics i could put it in fancier
terms but i'll just leave it at that
no theological political quarrels
what the preachers were saying on
sundays
and publishing in their pamphlets they
were praising the kind of government
that these guys were debating in the
convention
they were saying we need a government
and these guys were saying
we need that government that the
ministers
are preaching on sundays there was no
quarrel
those of you who have read shakespeare's
history place
know about the corals that they were
having in england
you know burke says one of the great
advantages of the
of the english constitution is that we
succession
is built into the constitution we don't
have any quarrels about king dies
next king is right there king dies the
next king is right there well
was he right about that read the uh read
the
shakespeare history play what are all
the wars about who's the next king is
going to be right
so these guys couldn't fix everything
but they fixed as much as they could
and they went further than anybody that
declaration of independence
was a world historical event
that changed the world and is still
changing the world
you see those people over protesting
over in hong kong
what are these what are they holding up
declaration of independence
and other places in the world that was a
world historical event they couldn't
they couldn't put it into effect all at
once
look ideas are rarely
capable of implementation all at once am
i right about that
you can't translate theory into practice
all at once
you go as far as you can while you can
without destroying the basis for going
free and that's what they did
and they were born into a world they
didn't create just like all the rest of
us
and they knew their obligation to change
the world for the better
and they went further i am sure of this
they went further than any other
generation in history
and that's what i'm trying to say people
say today look
this american founding was low and
loathsome
it relied on low ideas bad ideas
radically modern ideas you've heard of
all of this
there are hundreds of books and there
are hundreds of books that are being
written
today about this and it is simply not
true radically modern ideas locke was a
radical
uh radical modern guy
he thought that private interests were
the only engine of
politics and that people ought to be
selfish they ought not to
think about virtue and all of the good
things or the public good
the public interest or pursuit of
happiness meant
just do what is in your own
self-interest don't think about anybody
else don't think about your country
simply not true all you have to do is go
and study it took me four years of
concentrated study
this essay on human understanding where
he talks about
the pursuit of happiness is an 800 page
book
and it is densely written densely
written
see these glasses here i didn't have to
have glasses before i started reading
them
i can't think of a better point to stop
[Music]
them
you